Russia invades Ukraine and the response
from the rest of the world
sanctions and condemnation Ukraine's
President says that's not good enough so
what can be done to stop this war this
is Inside Story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
Muhammad
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is the
biggest threat to peace in Europe since
World War II but the international
response so far has been called weak and
ineffective at the United Nations
security Council permanent member Russia
used its veto to block a move against
The Invasion India the United Arab
Emirates and China abstained Russia
which currently holds the council's
rotating presidency says the resolution
was imbalanced for not mentioning the
Ukrainian government's own attacks on
the donbos region
we want to thank those who did not
support this draft I will not respond to
those who accuse the Russian Federation
of abusing the right to veto one of the
main reasons for our negative vote is
not what is included in the draft but
what is left out
how we can trust you
how we can trust your Assurance you have
no idea what is on the mind of your
president
your words have less value that than a
whole in the New York pretzel you can
veto this resolution but you cannot veto
our voices
you cannot veto the truth
you cannot veto our principles you
cannot veto
the Ukrainian people
the U.S and the European Union are
preparing sanctions directly targeting
Russia's president and foreign minister
the EU says it intends to freeze their
assets abroad the block had already
announced measures targeting 70 percent
of Russia's banking system and it
expects to decide soon on whether to
exclude the country from Swift a global
system for financial transactions former
Russian president Dimitri Medvedev
responded by saying Moscow doesn't
really need diplomatic ties with the
West
Ukraine's president said Western allies
aren't doing enough to stop the war
fellow damir zielinski wants to see more
demonstrations within Russia and across
the world
in every country of the world in every
country of Europe take to the streets
and demand peace for Europe and peace
for Ukraine demand and end to this war
this is our right this is your right
when bombs are falling in Kiev this is
not only in Ukraine it's in Europe when
Rockets are killing our people it's
death for everyone for every European
demand more protection for Europe more
protection for Ukraine as part of a
democratic world
all right let's bring in our panel in
leviv in Western Ukraine Michael busser
q a senior fellow at the Atlantic
Council and a former spokesperson for
the organization for security and
cooperation in Europe
in Moscow Natalia pelivina a political
activist and British Russian playwright
and in Alexandria Virginia P.J Crowley a
former U.S assistant Secretary of State
a warm welcome to you all and thank you
so much for joining us today on Inside
Story Michael let me start with you you
are currently in leviv I want to ask you
first how things are there right now
what are you seeing and what are you
hearing
sure thanks for having me well just uh
before we went on air here um Air Raid
Sirens were blaring outside with
announcements for everyone to shelter in
place and so on uh that started at six
a.m this morning and is repeating
intermittently almost to the point where
people don't know what to do um outside
on the streets calm but a lot of shops
closed uh pharmacies that sort of thing
I'm saying it's it's heartbreaking to
see but you're seeing a lot of families
couples that sort of thing with
suitcases getting ready to go I think
some of them don't even know where
they're going to go because it's so
difficult to move around
um we're hearing of lineups or cues
rather to the Polish border of several
several hours so uh most of the
diplomats we hear are gone I heard this
morning that diplomats from some of the
neighboring Baltic Nations have departed
that was about two days after the
Canadians did and then one last thing
we're seeing which is relatively new is
um new anxiety from possible salvators
uh you see more police uh military types
going around checking papers on a couple
of cases taking people away so
um that's that's um quite concerning if
indeed those types of people are here
now
PJ we know that sadly all the various
rounds of diplomacy leading up to this
failed to bring about a diplomatic
solution do you believe that going
forward there is a window that would
exist for potential diplomatic activity
well I think that once you unleash a
major military a gravitational force you
know takes over
um the military that we see
um uh coming from Belarus Crimea and
Russia
um will probably
um you know proceed forward until either
it achieves its initial objective one
would assume that's the uh seizure of
the government in Kiev uh or it meets
unexpected resistance you know I think
there clearly will be a window that
develops where diplomacy can re-engage
but I think that window is some time off
Natalia we've heard that Russian
officials are signaling a willingness to
hold diplomatic talks but do we know
under what conditions the Kremlin would
consider any kind of negotiation
well no
um we're putting Putin has initially
coming from
um what he has proposed to the West
um in terms of securing Russian uh
borders in terms of NATO closeness to
the Russian borders and Ukraine on
joining NATO Etc
that has never been something that
Western West really properly considered
and I don't believe they will therefore
in Putin knows at this point that that's
not going to happen so I don't really
see any uh result for negotiations
taking place I think that is pretty much
off the table at this point
um on on both sides so I think there are
there may be talks you know coming
you're surfacing once in a while that
some things along those lines is uh is
possible honestly very few people at
this point have faith in that at least
in Russia Michael from your Vantage
Point do you believe that there are any
diplomatic strategies that could be
employed to try and bring about some
kind of a solution or is it just too
late
sadly no and it is too late
um I was saying for the past weeks that
uh the Diplomatic toolbox was empty
there's as you know a lot of long table
or Shuttle diplomacy going on but it
didn't seem to move Putin I think that
uh Redline was drawn very very clearly
when Putin gave that uh very bizarre
long speech uh the blood curdling speech
about you know how he sees Ukraine as a
failed State
um how he wants to essentially redraw
the security map of Europe so
um I think that the West now belatedly
realizes that they're trying to make up
with new offers of weaponry and money
but you know given the current situation
and your correspondence today really
outlined it uh very starkly is that uh
you know I I as Putin further isolates
Ukraine militarily surrounds cities it's
going to be very difficult to go get
those resupplies to the front line to
the operational lines so um and even in
a best case scenario I know this from
work taking several emergencies in the
humanitarian Aid field is once the
disaster happens it's very difficult for
entities to absorb new funding or new
supplies unless you have a really good
strategy so many many complex parts to a
story that doesn't look like it went
very well PJ let me get your point of
view on this the latest rounds of
sanctions that have been announced
against Russia against President Putin
against foreign minister lavrov are
these enough or also is this too little
too late
well I think it's important to impose a
cost on Russia you know for what it is
doing in Ukraine uh invading a sovereign
country uh you know out of the the whims
and fears of a despotic leader
um so that is important uh it's not to
deter Russia at this point uh in a sense
you know these kinds of actions first
and foremost are to you know reassure
you know NATO allies that uh you know
there there is a cost to pay for these
and then you know secondly to to
maintain the unity of the alliance and
as Michael was alluding to to the extent
that the outside world can you know to
try to help uh you know Ukraine your
resist and survive uh by a variety of
means economic military and political
Natalia is there significant opposition
in Russia to President Putin's Ukraine's
strategy right now we know that there
have been protests we know that many
people were arrested for protesting I
mean have you been out there protesting
do you think there will be more protests
and and does any of this worry President
Putin
well I went out
um wrapped in the Ukrainian flag uh
yesterday
um and I was not detained but I was
questioned by the police on a number of
occasions and they took my my details ID
details down I will go out tomorrow for
sure uh it is likely that me and my
colleagues will be detained tomorrow
because that's what police said that's
the police's reaction at this point a
very harsh Detention of anyone who goes
out there to protest against this war
but that's not going to stop us
um does this scare Putin probably not he
has uh other things to deal with
um and this is you know this has become
a norm in recent years
very few protests were allowed to happen
without massive detentions so uh you
know the opposition has been largely
crushed however we aren't very much
coming together now and um I'm sure you
know outside our circles a lot of people
are told by what's going on there is a
certain percentage I don't know I
wouldn't be able to say what it is of
people in Russia who do only solely
listen to Russian propaganda and believe
everything Putin is saying basically
that there is no war there's a liberty a
military operation aimed at liberating
uh the eastern Ukraine but I don't know
how many of those people exist but I
know they do exist unfortunately but
they're we're hoping that there will be
a pushback
um
coming up soon from a lot of Russian
people and this is not just because they
don't agree with the with the military
actions in war in Ukraine
um it's also the economic
um the nation that will follow and then
very much the significant impact that
we're gonna gonna see happen in Russia
as a result of this complete tragedy
Michael I saw you nodding along to some
of what Natalia was saying there so I
want to give you the opportunity to jump
in if you'd like to but I also want to
ask you if you know from your Vantage
Point if you think that the fact that
there have been protests in Russia even
at this early stage if that is something
that is worrying to President Putin
yeah well we'd like to think that it is
uh but as we saw in in Belarus and you
know with the navani protests they were
crushed very very harshly look I think
in terms of
um uh inflicting pain on the uh Circle
or Ron Mister Putin and not Mr Putin
itself
um I and other experts at the Atlantic
Council have said that what needs to be
done is to make a Russian oligarch
outside the Russian borders feel
worthless uh that they will be Persona
no grata or some took to even arrest the
moment they step outside Russia so no
more trips on their expensive Yachts or
privatized to the French Riviera to
Miami New York whatever that is finished
and they have to understand that on
Saturday
um today a Russian ship was uh well
reportedly um uh sees by French
authorities and uh the ownership
connection with there was made with an
Associate of Putin that's the type of
stuff that needs to happen
one more thought on that um I think
sadly like we've seen in other theaters
of War or conflict if you will is that
the ordinary person is actually going to
feel that pain whether it's higher
prices for food or inability to travel
that sort of thing but I I cannot help
but think that Western strategists are
thinking maybe that is one way a
strategy is to make it so kind of vast
these sanctions that the Russian people
will say we're fed up
um you know we're claustrophobic we feel
isolated and an uprising could happen
that way but um I I believe is going to
what Natalia said that could be quite
some ways off PJ I also saw you reacting
to some of what Michael was saying there
so I want to I want to give you the
chance to um to jump in but but I also
want to ask you when it comes to all of
the diplomacy that that led up to this I
did diplomats at least Western diplomats
grossly underestimate what President
Putin would ultimately do
I actually I don't think so
um the Biden Administration
um had a very public strategy much of
what it said uh in the build up of
Russian forces and the potential for the
kind of invasion we're seeing has
actually occurred
um it's not something that I've I've
seen in in in my you know decades a long
career uh so so no I I don't think uh it
was underestimated I I do think that we
have to kind of step back and understand
that yes we're in the middle of a a
heightening crisis uh but but this is a
war that has been going on for at least
eight years uh you know where uh when
the yanyakovich government fell in 2014
uh Putin has been you know uh
maneuvering building up the ability to
try to you know reimpose uh a a situ an
order in you Ukraine that he could
control so so
um if if you want to talk about
um you know perhaps uh underestimating
what Putin was capable of doing uh
probably certainly that underestimation
occurred in 2014 2015 far more than it
did in 2021 and 2022. Natalia what do
you think the Western diplomats who were
involved in trying to avert this
Invasion do you think that they were out
of their depths did they fail to grasp
the psychology of President Putin and
what he was willing to do
well I think
um the West underestimated Putin for for
a very long time now I myself had
conversations at the state department in
Washington 10 years ago when I said uh
look he's gonna show his true colors
sooner or later you everyone will suffer
and and they went uh and bring the
response well no we don't see that
happening he will stay within the
borders at the very he's not going to do
anything yes he will repress his own
people you know and uh in the opposition
too bad you know
um but he's not going to go much further
than that that was real conversation I
had 10 years ago and now look what we
have right so uh there's been huge
underestimation of of Putin
unfortunately we the opposition kind of
saw this coming I hate to be saying it
but it's true
um and it all happened
um what we kind of course did foresee
for many years now
um and unfortunately we weren't really
heard properly within Russia or or
Beyond Russian borders so um now you
know now it's too late you know we have
this monster how do we deal with this
monster with a nuclear power I don't
know we have to come up with something
but that I think that is what the world
is Wrecking it's brain uh to uh to try
and figure out
um and it remains to be seen what what
will come to what solution is is
possible
Michael you know former Russian
president Medvedev has said that Russia
doesn't really need diplomatic ties with
the West
is that really the case I mean is
President Putin so insulated right now
that it doesn't matter to him if
diplomatic ties exist going forward or
not
oh yeah there's no question uh remember
um after the illegal annexation of
Crimea Russia was booted out of the
wealthy Club of Nations the G7 so
um and then a couple of years after that
I believe it was I actually wrote this
an op-ed it I was hearing that he's not
even interested in rejoining that club
so I see I think we're seeing
um a lot of disengagement from Russia
look uh I think it was better himself
who said wow that's great we won't have
to you know adhere to uh human rights
protocols uh we won't have to Arms
Agreements are out the window even you
know climate agreements they will their
isolation will further lead them I
believe into a tighter Embrace with
China this has been happening over time
as you know and um let there be no doubt
here whatsoever is the Chinese are
watching this very very carefully
because the Lessons Learned out of this
will help them design their eventual um
takeover of Taiwan it's this thing has
enormous enormous consequences that will
go on for years
it sends a chill down my back to say
this but I don't think the world will be
the same ever again the way we know it
and it's a very sad day I think PJ you
know Michael was just talking there
about the fact that he believes China
will be watching this very closely
um how much concern is there among
members of the Biden Administration as
to what comes next as to how much U.S
credibility is on the line as to what
impact this will have when it comes to
Future diplomacy when it comes to
dealing with other autocratic leaders
and States how much does this worry them
well I I think it it is
um not only Norm shattering uh but
system shattering uh you know we we this
is the beginning of a a new era in
international relations uh and and we're
going to have to make you know some
adjustments
um I you know I I think
um you know to Natalia's Point
um you know Putin is now completely
unmasked you know so um the first
challenge is to
um is what we do you know outside of the
borders of Ukraine you know for example
despite uh you know what happened in
2014 uh you know oil and gas uh imports
from Russia actually increased over the
last several years rather than decreased
you know so um to the extent that Russia
does have leverage over the
International System because of its
export of oil gas and other minerals it
is vitally important for the West to
find ways to to alleviate that leverage
that that Putin has and I think it's
going to be critically important the
Michael's reference to to China and
Taiwan is spot on
um and and it is it is I think going to
be a a major
initiative to try to drive a wedge uh
between Russia and China and there's an
opportunity to do that you know China
speaks all the time about the sanctity
of State sovereignty uh and yet they're
obviously fudging you know what is
happening in Ukraine uh I think it would
be important for the United States and
others to to drive home to Xi Jinping
you know there's no free lunch here if
you if you sign with Putin they're going
to be eventually be consequences to you
as well
Natalya is there anything that would
make President Putin want to back down
at this stage
could be I mean the guy has gone mad uh
not even within the last couple of
months but
a long time before that I don't know if
you know about his phrase that he
publicly said about uh you know
basically hinting at the possibility of
using uh nuclear
um Power of Russia when he said that we
as a Russians will go to heaven and
everyone else will just die like dogs I
didn't know if you've heard of this but
you could Google it it's out there it's
it's his actual phrase he said publicly
and it's it's you know you can find it
so with that kind of person who has
already gone this far and we now know
that there was no one around to stop him
to kind of alter this decision-making
process to to influence him there is no
one so at this point I don't know what
can what can happen to make him stand
back I mean the guy is his
he's lost his mind I mean that if you're
in power for that long and you have that
much of an ego as he does you know
that's it it's a recipe for catastrophe
so you know let's just pray we survive
this and there is no Third World War
and then we can talk what we do next
Michael based on what you are observing
on the ground there in leviv and also
from what you're observing about what's
going on geopolitically right now just
how dangerous a moment do we find
ourselves in
incredibly dangerous and again being on
the ground here and you know I've been
was in cave before here and then now
here in Viv it's just absolutely
heartbreaking to see what's happening to
nuclear families here small businesses
uh Civil Society you know it's really
um tough on people here and
um you know I think what could be a
difference here from other conflicts you
know that could seem very far away you
know in Africa or Middle East or
whatever I mean these are Europeans that
we're seeing uh being killed one more
quick point if I can I think um what uh
the West needs to do urgently and I
think you're well the previous guess
alert to this is that um the United
States is going to have to lead I think
the effort to lessen its dependence on
oil and gas from Russia and
unfortunately one of the Brave decisions
well not brave but perhaps both
decisions Biden is going to have to take
very soon is to open up fracking again
that sort of thing not not necessarily
environmentally friendly practices in
order to achieve this goal
um we're going to pay a price for that
as well in terms of perhaps a more you
know dirtier environment and things like
that but that leverage to reduce that
leverage Russia has over the rest of the
world and over Europe especially it's
very very important the discussion has
given us a lot to think about but
unfortunately we have run out of time so
we're going to have to leave it there
thank you so much to all of our guests
Michael Buster Q Natalia pelivina and PJ
Crowley
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website Al jazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story you can
also join the conversation on Twitter
our handle is at AJ inside story from me
Mohamed room and the whole team here bye
for now
foreign